pack the perfect healthy picnic for
national picnic month
registered dietitian mia sin shares
five-minute snack lunches
a bubbly beverage with benefits and how
to lighten up
summer wraps and pasta take a look
hey las vegas now summertime calls for
picnics
so find a shady spot to enjoy this easy
and nutritious spread starting with
wraps two ways with a low carb twist
these veggie wraps and caprese wraps are
made with a base of egg life egg white
wraps which are an innovative take on
traditional tortillas made with
cage-free eggs instead of flour
so have five grams of protein and less
than one gram of carbs and 35 calories
per wrap
they come in five varieties that you can
find at sprouts smiths
and smart and final including southwest
italian rye
and everything bagel for this veggie
wrap start with the original wrap and
add spinach
cucumber bell pepper carrot sprouts and
avocado roll it up and cut it into rolls
for this caprese wrap start with the
italian style wrap and add
arugula mozzarella tomato basil and
avocado
fold it up and serve for picnic goers
who want a five minute option
try these snack lunch boxes simply
combine your protein produce good fats
and whole grains to build a satisfying
lunch box
for protein i used the all-natural beef
snacks raised
sustainably and responsibly in nebraska
without the use of antibiotics or added
hormones
this beef is known for being lean but
tender making it a delicious dietitian
approved option
you can find it at peedmontice.com to
ship straight to your door
next add veggies fruit whole grains and
nutritious dips for good fats
feel free to get creative with different
protein produce whole grains and healthy
fats
as long as you follow this formula it's
easy to put together satisfying meals
next we have my pasta salad in a jar
made with a pasta that contains nearly
zero calories
this pasta in a jar is made with a base
of miracle noodle which is a traditional
shirataki noodle that originated in
japanese cuisine made with konjac root
and contains
97 water and 3 fiber the miracle noodle
rice and noodles have only 5 calories
per serving no fat sugar or starch and
can be used as a substitute in
traditional pasta and rice dishes
for this recipe add arugula cherry
tomatoes red onion
avocado and bacon bits to a large mixing
bowl then add your shirataki noodles
olive oil lemon juice and salt and
pepper toss to combine and add to your
jars
finally i have a beverage with benefits
that's portable and perfect for your
picnic
poppy is a bubbly drink made with apple
cider vinegar and prebiotics which are a
type
of fiber that helps selectively nourish
the good bacteria in the gut which helps
support a healthy immune system
unlike traditional soda it's low in
calories and sugar but still comes in
delicious flavors like ginger lime
watermelon and my favorite the
strawberry lemon
i hope you enjoyed these tips and
recipes you can find them at my website
nutritionbymia.com and nutritionbymia on
instagram where i also share meal ideas
and nutrition tips daily